[inaudible] a complex decision.
[inaudible] um,
uh,
[inaudible] participate with the Ba,
sid
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Fossa loopy keepers.
[inaudible] uh,
gender Hosteria don't
[inaudible] [inaudible] politic.
No one ever
[inaudible] [inaudible] concerned they're less Christian.
Will encourage the farm on Pachulia.
Would you key you teach Nokia?
Yeah.
You have an MPI chief [inaudible] Audrey [inaudible] say dupont silicate of
wholesome lot.
Look
[inaudible] [inaudible] on the declare has shown [inaudible] this actor or this
is your nap boutique economic may [inaudible] that dash mom.
I still can't sleep.
[inaudible] Kumar SPKs this business schizophrenia,
putting TK and develop
shovey a pawn.
This example,
keystone on this example,
all the back trailer does exemplar,
um,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] plus the feminism now associative horses in the absolute
amount.
Blah.
[inaudible] he said [inaudible] Ooh,
optimistic.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
on totally feminism.
Study of feminism.
The Form Pella man shows on [inaudible].
It says
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] mom,
all that work.
Uh,
uh,
liters manager had domestic and so on.
Costuming
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Amazon Domestique uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh,
equal to two [inaudible] competency.
Gal.
I don't have it again.
Also,
how to the depot song.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] school,
uh,
these on phone,
if he the ACSM lown it also among the key Tonko hormone,
the Doula complementarity,
the sexy number.
No amount of the [inaudible] it is
[inaudible] [inaudible] technique.
Also,
this [inaudible] left.
It's tumor.
The past memory to took in lecture hall.
You see them?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] regardless,
PC additives and new plastic [inaudible] Hong Kong [inaudible]
don't like
[inaudible]. [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
and his fiance won't back to Japan.
SEAPCO Lee competents.
So hypothetic many [inaudible] population of Jose [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
don't Comos too thick.
She said
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] complimentarity one.
It don't do appraisal concerns aside,
you position on a street,
uh,
don't go back to cleo capital compared me to eat balanced on par.
Yeah.
Uh,
don't get Katy.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] doctor mom,
Eh,
don't come to work yet.
Do Sushi.
[inaudible] Lee presents you bought [inaudible] uh,
the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] no lottery hall.
So,
Ooh,
so
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] is a fair and lucky,
so sweats on [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and he's wanting to come back
Sunday area new [inaudible] don't come in.
[inaudible] passie PLA is one application on particularly delegative Emma
[inaudible] articulate cds anymore.
Terrapin one lady backyard was Audrey
[inaudible] [inaudible] ski concerned.
They'll leave you alone.
So 60,
[inaudible] uh,
so when I say
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and community knowledge.
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] me or they can put the,
uh,
the [inaudible] and
on [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
Ilya [inaudible].
Yeah.
Not how the badge is.
Should we do literature didn't receive a completely free to Applique [inaudible]
system,
eh,
uh,
of work.
Your law [inaudible] do not difficulty.
I did pass.
This was [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] cities on farms cause San Porto.
If you buy a car home for the wide,
who to retail for hematologists or educational.
Okay.
Marshall [inaudible] if you don't feel bad,
[inaudible] senior.
The manifesto on senior NCO fuser don't sneaker the masculine on portfolio.
Feminine Hygiene with Jeremy [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
in a professor her.
Did he touch your energy?
Know I'm on trade.
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] and [inaudible] linguistic
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] proximity
[inaudible] [inaudible] all of course you [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh,
the shopkeepers,
it's heavy on new GMC.
Don't go boom with dorma come dizzy a new year.
It's a purpose condition.
She has a plastic [inaudible].
Dot.
[inaudible] word Adelante feminist message.
He may or may make [inaudible] cetera.
Um,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it could,
don't sit it [inaudible] illegitimate.
It'll be a [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] pops conditions to kill the ready column.
[inaudible] uh,
on the zone let loose.
Usually by the
[inaudible] [inaudible] gala.
[inaudible] preschool
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] center is sound.
The work on quite low and it doesn't pull up.
Politique don't
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] question Bama self hundred in the alphabet.
Uba,
uh,
Mickey [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] town and almost cause the CQC metal.
His mom posey sampling [inaudible] Pentecostal acquired a poker.
And are they also put up politically Poe compounder.
Suki suppressors.
Audrey [inaudible] super hot docs that contradict shown it to [inaudible] any
day.
Wow.
Honey.
Contribute,
I think normally renew.
If for [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] community Politica [inaudible] don't
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] don't [inaudible].
Uh,
[inaudible] uh,
the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Sophia [inaudible] bunny poison ivy
[inaudible] capacity dual at Hanford.
Uh,
don't support me.
Matt [inaudible].
Matt Kitu litigated I Liberte tool application on the policy for an amount to
pulling off or motif.
Uh,
the not one that you had superior
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] feminism.
We won't produce the only two.
Only 12.
Innovate a fundamental [inaudible] not [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] um,
[inaudible] uh,
therapy.
Massive.
Emma Hashtag [inaudible] manifested his ego.
We knew this bleak.
A Como [inaudible] back to we put [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Pharma or normally legality.
CECI Manny FECA
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a fundamental don't contradict.
Wow.
Who Possibility prescale kid gets killed?
The ELD [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Ivig.
What would the [inaudible] prison
don't,
don't say [inaudible] to burn.
Uh,
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it harder to,
to [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] on the tax to do.
How do you get
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] literally shown
these unique entity you don't twice argument Laponia argument and it dupont the,
so I said take Nika
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] because you know,
there's actually critiques.
I'm pretty sure tiny [inaudible] seek left hospital.
An example,
putty Tika as cleaners.
You need to our long song,
Lucy don't receive the economist to Medicaid.
[inaudible]
and [inaudible] and [inaudible] don't [inaudible] partition.
Delicious.
He stood in the limit,
you know,
have a really strong glass.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] the Getty Sheila
Aboriginal [inaudible] on antiquities.
[inaudible] Cola.
I'm going to complete may,
uh,
what ESCO [inaudible] leverage of how says it preserved is chosen dynamics
usually seat.
Elaborate to the privilege.
Legal [inaudible] shot again.
He did it.
Why they chose you left your see [inaudible] could a good CV gown till they get
it.
It absolutely a coachable fast food.
What copy a day.
I said,
read the contracted Ebola.
Mom emailed her bound.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] on the [inaudible].
Good set to get it.
The new [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Irma,
the teller characteristic of
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] lecture.
I'm sick.
Same vaccine or songs.
The whole Lombard steady hacker in [inaudible] 70 [inaudible] to get it.
It comes,
he really fucked.
If she saw it.
Don't met Humper Fmla,
Hong Kong [inaudible] pound Tessa.
He may have [inaudible]
don't [inaudible] and capacity.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
complementarity [inaudible] swell up is because of
[inaudible] [inaudible] very prolonged over.
For example,
about the city to come sell the diabetic wet [inaudible] surely [inaudible] some
priests.
He Scad works on both horses every day of good.
Uh,
Alpen one risk.
Hello La [inaudible],
uh,
[inaudible],
[inaudible] shoe.
What I put on.
Some may say,
perhaps a or digital,
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] and then I see now says [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] to tests to stay a hundred present way.
It was,
he pointed produce risk is on [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] upon the decision preschool as Ellie.
Finally,
please do his kids and [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] who's also pure oil.
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
uh,
the two,
the testosterone,
uh,
don't call never Hamamatsu measles.
Send us at
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I'm a member of it.
Uh,
don't go it.
[inaudible] Paula promotional at diversity preschool songs.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
the [inaudible] complementarity neoliberal.
Don't [inaudible] feminism [inaudible] society.
Uh,
Eh,
I'm am Dunker [inaudible] look to sa [inaudible] Jeremy [inaudible],
the New Yorker.
Yom [inaudible].
Uh,
[inaudible] dog will mail.
I know Luke problem seeker.
Don't call it
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] don't [inaudible] moment.
Don't movie or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] plus on [inaudible] campus.
Cute on Sam credential is could at least on battery.
Qda
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a student also Hong Kong.
Sicker it.
[inaudible] it.
We'll see.
[inaudible] [inaudible] visit statey performative said
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] song called
[inaudible] still fossil different
[inaudible] [inaudible] passes it,
compliment it.
Uh,
make your
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] don't tell you that he can sell a folio
platform is to sear,
uh,
[inaudible] phones.
Uh,
uh,
no one had the false,
no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or [inaudible],
especially [inaudible] uh,
may onto capital if he knows a lead.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
off to the Preuss.
[inaudible] what?
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] in both Pharma in family key key,
key secondary it solely where Cuomo,
uh,
listen [inaudible] let me see,
see,
that is on top,
please.
You get grounded was at PNG.
[inaudible] nomadic jam is highly [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
uh,
[inaudible] she did that for my show.
The [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] patty doc on it.
[inaudible] she didn't have her
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] lets you,
uh,
is it
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] is [inaudible] Qualcomm the fear [inaudible]
legality.
Qualcomm two faces on the field of [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] of Jose.
A different strategy.
Keep
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] particularly Pharma,
Eh,
uh,
[inaudible] me.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] don't [inaudible] version the familiar Assisi offer this
economy.
Akasha who screwed?
I said [inaudible] uh,
the Trois [inaudible] the project some songs for some to media.
The war shows again.
Yep.
[inaudible] won't take [inaudible] feminism.
[inaudible] do whole e
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] we did a [inaudible] don't
[inaudible] [inaudible] a fear and hover your bachelor testing show the civic
[inaudible] on Shondra unique mold design.
Decent.
Leah [inaudible] equity,
Eh,
Alissa
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] nonpartisan.
This law,
uh,
they get some additional,
suddenly she's going onto the numbers.
Could be severe.
Domo get to leak.
No.
Seeing the reality.
So this communist Yola uh,
it don't [inaudible] leisure problem at exam should have a problem.
[inaudible] [inaudible] steadier,
separate barite went back to
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Christian model could discriminate.
[inaudible] gala
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] per metric ton machine memory guilty Donovan
Popo [inaudible] sell the whole strategy.
De-Bone [inaudible] because see,
almost like,
uh,
Lizzie negated stone tablet,
some Hibah that jump with metal component set to
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
the set [inaudible] those are Iijima care hygiene.
Politically public can dignity,
uh,
you know,
hygiene [inaudible] don't uh,
[inaudible] uh,
yes,
it necessity on the excisions uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Ooh,
don't screw on properly.
I was six years maybe.
I'm very young and career Lee family [inaudible] is click
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] on a space,
a public political economic impact to the usual [inaudible] soft core fee,
uh,
and uh,
to,
uh,
improve value.
Don't as best you bleaker,
but meals for too long.
God.
Have you got those?
You know,
society says at all.
[inaudible]
about hosting [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] like [inaudible] person [inaudible] the manifest as you
want to say.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] this ex though on paper,
ideally,
I suppose.
Cipla Mellow La
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] La
[inaudible] tablet.
Any performance cause Japan legalities to condition the performance [inaudible]
performance or some self for the medical center.
The [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] to bell though.
[inaudible] the performance,
the performance.
You want to tell him,
you see the performance of
[inaudible] [inaudible] on call number,
uh,
the,
the trouble chemo [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
don't [inaudible] to remind the most young putty ticket complex work.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] this year.
So when he gets too bad,
it was a demonic,
a little objective syllabi.
Active city [inaudible] okay.
On the ivy set objectives that they do.
[inaudible].
No,
her sister [inaudible].
There are many [inaudible] Kadama constitutional
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] says what?
Prelaunch group on term digital antipyretic on Hipaa.
Uh,
don't
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] dot com and move fam on their normal fam.
Uh,
do television.
So sell your television at neutral.
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] Siskey Fella,
he stressor [inaudible] she has to do so city.
Um,
don't go longer.
If I'm on the Pesach,
factset bought it.
What would not even has to be held for that fraternity?
It is so gorgeous.
Tala.
Yeah.
Pouncey Swain community politics overseas.
The lead.
Then she takes the [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] on the Tuesday.
I'm a man of God,
let us use it.
But Sebastiani,
uh,
in
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] hotels individually
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] it's also kind of [inaudible] in politics is so
[inaudible] said set utopia.
Anto suitcase,
TD rate that it don't we CNOC legis [inaudible] so [inaudible] new restroom to
constantly restaurant men.
Politik NOCI
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] back to you to pick
the whole project.
[inaudible]
DOXA this kid duty to people while Amar geopolitical,
a model on this show for
[inaudible]. [inaudible] [inaudible] who can do [inaudible] don't
[inaudible] [inaudible] Blah Blah.
[inaudible] see just you have a concern.
[inaudible] luxury mal seizures.
Judah [inaudible] there a lot.
A dunce killer.
The demeanor among women in minimum bull,
uh,
Mlo has mama Vic nuber collage.
[inaudible] only two only don't to self.
Don't set to bell projects from La.
[inaudible] uh,
uh,
the sock time.
Uh,
don't categorize on the electric em in new Coleman.
C'Mon.
[inaudible] Bordeaux conservers
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] the cloud on ever amount.
Don't,
don't,
don't delusion the [inaudible] coming community.
I mean community gala [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] summary,
but the [inaudible] performance.
[inaudible] what else?
[inaudible] business.
Yeah,
but Malka soft [inaudible] it'll get to the [inaudible] [inaudible] where put a
diversity scams.
You've got [inaudible] postal responsibilities.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] cause I don't see Toyota.
Lou [inaudible] uh,
the long family Fairmont on the category don't deserve [inaudible] La.
No,
Tom Odell,
uh,
don't go a long career hotel.
[inaudible]
don't,
don't leave.
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] some condition.
Mess.
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
Oh,
Colette lesson.
Isiah
explicit.
A CDP mom.
Okay.
Um,
kiss cute.
What we found new
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I don't so said to
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] well,
a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a [inaudible] the the uh,
the cashflow.
Uh,
don't kiss kiss config fam.
[inaudible] complex.
Huh?
The [inaudible] complex.
Uh,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I think he called you wants it by me.
Um,
[inaudible] uh,
as to dia about Escuela.
[inaudible] she'll,
she found Tom [inaudible] says
[inaudible] [inaudible] well,
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] um,
[inaudible] it.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] took us.
So Tim
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] sorry.
Condition.
The possibility.
Legality it Poli Stony.
Conditioned them.
Possibility legality.
Sweats.
You back three weeks as well.
Marsha [inaudible] Patrick,
it,
it repels Government de Monterrey Park,
cause he's ridiculous.
He's bisexual amounts.
So I'll leave you alone.
Six trailer is exist at [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] of course issues to at already
least.
Yeah.
Do Someone Send Mila Act to the view loans a stuff.
Homes per home?
Yeah.
Get farmers.
[inaudible] plantain.
Yeah.
Depo Song.
The fake.
Here
are three to fund the Plantar [inaudible] [inaudible] ready doc.
Okay.
[inaudible] mask and you mitigate it down.
[inaudible] village is less.
Hume immerse my books like is totally.
She shows you the war.
[inaudible] [inaudible] guess give Reggie come come,
come possibility.
[inaudible] ready.
Conformity.
I see.
Can play a remote potentaty point.
[inaudible] Christian can migrate to [inaudible] on Nancy [inaudible].
[inaudible] it came a barometer,
the,
the whole way or quite fundamental on [inaudible] Adria [inaudible] new
[inaudible] de la ratably or develop Israel.
The welcome a non pressure.
Uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Lupita fundamentals you to walk he lesson
[inaudible] [inaudible] info.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] he said,
he said you do.
I feel like sweat systematic [inaudible] pressure.
Do certain zone properties.
The class.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] please keep in Wa it.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] making the door.
Absolutely.
Mamba.
She planted Ooh,
uh,
discreditable door outside the subway and that complain mount by their plate,
pap or the one and the old La [inaudible] or
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] wife.
Fundamental,
uh,
emotional Diplo,
could not do our public entities where we see fabulous.
You know,
Patrick [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
don't go
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
okay,
Merci beaucoup over.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] he was a VP of world membership delusion.
I love what [inaudible] by
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
says Google phone Seminoles the culture [inaudible]
I don't,
let's see.
[inaudible] um,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] specificity of houses.
Also Hong Kong [inaudible] page.
He's on the phone.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] on the categories as Sean [inaudible].
Uh,
[inaudible],
uh,
[inaudible] Washington Post
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] the difficult only
demand to Amanda,
uh,
[inaudible],
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
showing pleasure.
[inaudible] the [inaudible].
Um,
and does this a budget?
[inaudible] yes.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
then after that,
uh,
most religion.
All right.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] with Harvey [inaudible] title a Dvr.
Ct of his only hope.
Yardi hooper.
Lgptq uric hooper,
the [inaudible] hooper 40 black [inaudible]
go ahead.
[inaudible] and he's dead.
He died on particular need.
Shit gone on over deep.
I say
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] is that a statistic?
Uh,
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.